Welcome everyone to the session on foundation models in
pathology.
It's one o'clock, so we will get started.
Great to see everyone here, and I would like to start with thanking the
organization for inviting us to give this session.
So my name is Jeroen van der Laak. I'm a professor of computational pathology at
the Radboud University Medical Center in Nijmegen, the Netherlands.
I have a background in computer science, so I will not be very good in medical
stuff, but more in AI-related stuff.
And today with me is Dr. Jana Lipkova.
Jana started her career at the ETH in
Zurich, Switzerland.
She has her PhD in Munich, in Germany, in computer science.
And she was a postdoc at
Faisal Mahmood's lab in Harvard in Boston.
And now she's working as an assistant professor at University of California,
Irvine,
and she is with the Departments of Pathology and of Biomedical Engineering.
Nothing important that I forgot, I hope.
Nothing.
Okay.
And next to Jana is Professor Jakob Kater.
I think he's well known at this conference.
Professor Kater is Professor of Clinical Artificial Intelligence at the
Technical University of Dresden in Germany,
and he's also Senior Physician in Medical Oncology at University Hospital in
Dresden.
So he has a dual title as an MD and an MSC.
So I'm really happy to be able to
present today, the three of us.
And the way we will do this is I will give a brief introduction on the
topic
of foundation models in pathology and more broadly in medical imaging.
Then Jana will take over and she will talk about survival
prediction, so the use of foundation models for survival prediction.
And lastly, Professor Kater will take over and talk about
foundation models for cancer research.
Okay.
So my disclosures you can see here, and probably most importantly
I have a spinoff company which is called Aiosyn, which produces AI
products for pathologists.
Now,
very briefly to start off, I think everyone here knows what pathology is about.
Pathology is about tissue and doing diagnostics on
tissue sections. So what you can see here is very briefly, and I guess it's
very well known for most of you. What you can see is if we take a biopsy, we
can put it in paraffin. We embed it in paraffin.
We can take very thin sections, and those sections can be stained.
And as you are probably also aware of these days, there is a transition ongoing
in pathology, going from microscopes, traditional
microscopes, and a pathologist looking through an optical microscope.
And we are transitioning to what is shown here on the slides, scanners and
digital pathology. Which means a pathologist is no longer looking through a
microscope, but actually they are looking at a digital screen.
Now I think it's good to realize that this is a transition that's ongoing,
has been ongoing for maybe 15 years.
Still, most pathologists in the world are not digitized.
I think in the US it's less than 10% of the pathologists that uses digital
pathology. And the consequence, obviously, of that is that if you want to use any
kind of AI technology, fancy computational technologies, you will not
be able to do so. So this is a very important prerequisite that is still not
really being met at this time. So there is still quite a bit of work to be done.
Just to give you a feel for why this is so difficult and why it's so expensive.
One digitized biopsy has the same amount of data, gives us the same amount of data
as, for instance, three to five minutes of an HD movie.
So pathology has a lot of information.
It's very rich images, very rich data, but also it means that
it's a lot of data. So storing this and dealing with this data is actually quite
cumbersome.
Now, just to give you a feel of what AI could do, and this is work that we did in
our group, but many groups in the world did this kind of analysis.
We produce AI that is capable of analyzing prostate
cancer biopsies and
aiding a pathologist in grading those biopsies.
So it means that the AI is capable of finding visual patterns in these
images and is capable of assigning a grade to those
patterns.
And we have shown that actually you can produce AI that is at a
very high level of performance doing this.
Now, the downside is, and this is one of the studies that we did,
this is an international competition, the Panda Challenge that we organized a
couple of years ago. And what you can see here is that, for instance, to be
able to do this kind of challenge, to build this AI, we needed more
than 12,000 prostate biopsies, and we have more than
5,600 reviews by pathologists. So
you can build AI that is at a very high level of performance.
The price you pay is you need a lot of data. This is really truly big data.
And
what you can achieve then, and please don't go into too much detail, but these are
the
different AI algorithms in the challenge that we did and the competition that we
did.
What you can see here is that the
pinkish bars is that is the quadratic weighted Kappa
comparing the AI model to a panel of expert pathologists.
And what you can see is these Kappas go all the way up to .93, which is extremely
high. This is as good as any pathologist can be.
So if we have enough data, we can produce AI that is at an extremely high level.
What you can also see in this graph is the pink bars are
the algorithms tested on data that resembles the data it was trained on,
so what we call in-distribution data.
The purplish bars is a different cohort of
casesWhich is slightly different from the data that the
algorithms were trained on. And what you can see here is that generalizability of
these algorithms, as we call it, is not perfect.
So if I build an algorithm on certain data, I take it to slightly
different data, it could be that my performance degrades.
And this is one of the problems that we always have with AI, right?
Generalizability is not always perfect. And we'll get back to that later.
Now, just
a brief sidestep. So medical data is very diverse, right?
You know that we can have pathology images, we can have MRIs, we can have CTs, we
have lots of different modalities of data.
And basically what we aim to do in our research and in our developments,
we would love to be able to combine all these different modalities and
have some common ground where we can, let's say, analyze data,
combine data. So we need some kind of common language in between these
different sources of data. We also have genomics. We have patient records.
These are very different data, and we would like to have some kind of
representation of data that makes it easier to combine the data.
So we make a small sidestep. What we typically do in AI
is we
build representations of data, of data points,
like you can see here. And this is if you use a large language model, an LLM,
ChatGPT or Claude or one of these.
Every
data item
will be translated into what we call an embedding or feature representation,
which means we translate it into a
vector of numbers. And in this case, woman could be some kind of vector
of numbers, and suppose we would also have a man.
And this is a bit artificial, but you could think of, we have many different
characteristics of these data points that can be stored because they're relevant.
For instance, in this case, you could say,
how much does it resemble a living being? How much is it flying, human?
What is the gender? So we can store data points
in this large vector, and you can imagine that it's large
array of numbers. You can also see this mathematically as a point in a
high dimensional space. It's a bit sometimes difficult
to visualize that. But actually, what we typically do is
we take data points, and we put them in a vector of 700
numbers, which basically means we have 700 dimensional space.
Now, that's a lot, way too much to comprehend.
But what you will often see in many of these examples is that we then project a
space onto a plane, just to give you a bit of a feel for how well
separations are possible.
So, for instance, what we can say now is we have a way of
representing the concept of a man, a woman, a king, a queen,
and these can show up as points in the space.
And if two points are closer together, it means they also resemble each other
better.
And if you do it as well, you can also start to even use these numbers to
make calculations. So, for instance, what you could say now is if I have a queen,
the concept of a queen,
I take out gender, so I subtract woman from it, but I add man.
I will arrive at a king because I changed the gender of the
queen to become male, and now it's a king.
So if you make these representations well, what you can do is actually they make
sense, right? You can start to work with these.
And moreover, what we can do is we can add context, and this is what happens a lot,
for instance, in large language models.
So suppose we would have the concept of a fruit and of technology, and now I
have an apple in the context of what are the health benefits of
apple.
Now, this would mean that the context tells me that in this case, apple is
something close to fruit, while if I would have a context like what is the share
price of Apple, it would probably be something like technology.
So we can use context to
change these representations slightly.
It also means if I am in pathology, I have part of an image, some region of an
image. Regions around it in the tissue can help
me to understand what that region is about, right?
So also there, the context can help me to understand how to use that
embedding.
Now, this was about text. A similar thing we started to do
already 10, 15 years ago with images.
So we can also have representations of images, which are pretty much the same as I
just showed you for these words. So what we can do is we can
train a neural network in this case, and a neural network can pick up
all kinds of visual features
and result in an embedding in this high dimensional space.
And you can use that, let's say, that high dimensional space then to do, for
instance, image classification.
So in this case, we would find all kinds of visual features.
We would get a point in the space, and that point in the space could help us to
decide that this is Tweety. So again, here you can use these
embeddings to
analyze images, to analyze data points, and to represent data points.
Now, one of the problems, I already mentioned it briefly, is
generalization.
Because if we would
train a model like I just showed you, we have some embedding in the space,
then the embedding could be very much specific to the data that we use
to train it on.
And this is a very nice study that shows that here they produced
AI
that can predict the subtype of breast cancer.
So it can distinguish between lobular and ductal carcinomas.
And what they did was they trained an AI system on data, which is
predominantly of white females. So I think
70% is white, 5% is Asian, and
15%, 16%, I think, is Black females.
Now, what happens is that the AI, because it's trained on this
biased dataset, the AI will be better capable
of doing the task for white females than it will be for Asian females.
Because it has seen many more examples for whites.
And as a result, what happens is, if you look at the top of this figure, the
ResNet, so this is fully trained on these data.
What you can see is that the performance for whites is
over 0.9, 0.93, 0.92, while for Asians, it's
only 0.85So what you can see is because dataset is
biased, it's skewed, you can see the performance actually is also better
for white.
Now, if we go to the right in this bar, we can see CTranspath, and we can
see Uni. Now, these are examples of foundation models, the topic of today.
And what you can clearly see here is that CTranspath does a much better job.
It's less sensitive to this bias in the data. It's actually more robust.
And CTranspath and Uni are foundation models.
So they have been trained slightly differently than just task specific, what I
showed you so far.
So if we look at what happened in AI over the last 20,
30 years, in the 2000s, in machine learning, this
feature space that I told you about, this embedding space, we would really
let's say build it ourselves. We would think about the features ourselves.
We would manually derive these features.
In the 2010s, we would have deep learning, where we would use networks to learn
features. But they were very much task specific.
In the 2020s, we have foundation models, and foundation models try to build these
features
in a task independent manner. And I will show you how this works.
So rather than having an image and training
an AI system to do a specific task, what we now do is we
learn to extract representations that are very generic, that can be used
for many downstream tasks. So we just want to
translate this small image into, again, this kind of an embedding, so a vector of
numbers.
And these numbers should describe in very general sense what we are
looking at. So the shapes, the texture, the edges.
So it should describe in a very generic sense what is this image about.
And then that description, these characteristics can be used for any kind of
downstream task, for tumor detection, grading, but also outcome
prediction, for instance.
And I will not go into a lot of detail, but
this is what we call self-supervised learning.
It's the same thing that happened to ChatGPT.
You all probably know that ChatGPT just took loads of texts from the
internet, analyzed these texts without having a clear task in mind, and
just found all kinds of, let's say, patterns in the text that it can
use for downstream tasks, like generating new texts, understanding
text.
Now, the same happens here. We train our AI model on
pathology data without a specific task. We give it a dummy task.
But we give it a task that is very hard and that forces it to learn
many generic aspects of the data without having a specific task
in mind. If you're interested, you can look up the papers. It's very technical.
And if you have done this, you have a very generic representation of your data.
Then, for instance, what you can do is what is called few-shot learning.
So now I have let's say different types of kidney cancer.
What I can do is I can take a couple of examples of kidney cancer and see where
they end up in this high dimensional space.
And if I have three different types of kidney cancer, I take, in this case, three
examples of each. So I have some points in the space that are here, some points
that are here. Now, if I have a new cancer, what I can do is I can just
calculate its place in this space and then see is it closer to this or closer to
this point. So rather than having to take 10,000
examples, as I showed you for prostate cancer grading, in this case, I can
just take a couple of examples, and because I have such a rich embedding already,
I have this self-supervised system, I can already do great things
just with very little data points.
Now, this is what was done in this study.
So this is a study where they compared on one hand doing this, let's say,
task specific learning with lots of cases, thousands of cases, and they compare it
to the use of a foundation model.
And what they found was, and please have a look at this graph.
So here you can see on the X-axis, you see the amount of training data.
So they have thousands of cases. On the Y-axis, you can see the quality of the
AI that they built in this case.
What you can see is the blue line is just the task specific learning.
So this is what I showed you before.
You train a model to really perform this one task as good as you can.
And what you can see is this model, the blue line, is quite poor with
little data, but it has a steep curve, and if you provide it
with enough data, like 30% of the total here, you get a very high level of
performance.
The other two are based on foundation models.
And what you can see is that with very little data, as little as 1% of your
entire cohort, you can already have quite good performance.
Still, what is also clear in this chart is that if you
have enough data, the task specific model still outperforms the
foundation model. So if you have a lot of data, then a foundation model
may be less relevant because you can train it on a task
specific manner.
And the conclusion in this paper was that foundation models do great with little
data. If you have enough data, a task specific model could do better.
And what they found here was, especially for specific very rare pathologies, the
foundation model didn't do so well.
And one point that we may discuss later maybe is one of the
drawbacks of foundation models is because they're huge models, they're pre-trained,
and they're very large. In this case, the foundation model took up 35
times more energy than a task specific model.
So that's also a point to take into account, I guess.
Now, one of the great things about foundation models is that we don't have
to stick with just vision, as I showed you.
I told you we have these representations,
and what we can do is we can actually start to combine images with
text. In this case, they used text captions. They used images.
And what we can start doing now is we can build these self-supervised models, but
then we can take the texts,
combine the different embeddings, and use one embedding to make
the other one, let's say, more precise, as I showed you.
So you can use one as a context for the other.
So what they do here is they built these embeddings, and then they start to combine
these different modalities, and they refine their embeddings.
They refine their system.
And the great thing is now you can benefit not just from having the images, but
having a combination of an image with, for instance, a pathology
reportThis is still not task
specific. It's still very generic.
So it means that
we don't need any kind of labels. We can train
self-supervised this kind of a model with just pathology images and
maybe associated reports. And so we can have the AI
learn a lot of interesting features, interesting, let's
say, relationships, by just feeding it with lots of images and
lots of corresponding reports.
And
there are many of these models today. So this is one very recent, MuSi.
In this case, you can see they did this self-supervised training with
reports and with
slides.
And you can see actually that MuSi, in this case, it's not the largest model.
In terms of parameters, it's actually quite small.
And it has a very high score. And just to show you
a couple of tasks that it can do. So they
tested it on many different tasks, and for instance, it's very good
at predicting KRAS mutations from H&E slides.
So basically what it means is we can give it an H&E stained slide,
no fancy stainings, no fancy molecular analysis,
and it can already
predict quite well whether the tumor has a KRAS mutation.
So you can see here it has an F1 score of 0.85.
It can also do
histological grading. It can find other kinds of mutations.
So these foundation models can be a great foundation to build all these downstream
tasks that we may go into later.
Another one you can see here. So this is predicting response of
lung cancer to immune therapy.
What you can see here is if you do only images alone, you can see that it's
doable, but it's not performing great.
If you do it only on a pathology report, it's a bit less.
But if you combine the image and the report, then you can see that the combination
of the two is much stronger, and you can get to quite decent performance even
of 0.75, which is still not great, but you could see it's
definitely better than it was.
Now,
one thing
that is very important, and we may also touch upon that later in later
presentations,
foundation models are not always completely robust.
And
it means that what I set out to try and explain to you is
a foundation model can work with less data.
And because it was trained on a very large variety of data, you would like it to be
more robust than task-specific models.
So I showed you if we build a task-specific model and we try it out
on new data, it might not perform as well as it did on the data it was
trained on. And one of the great promises of foundation models, because it is
trained on a very large diversity of data, is that it will
generalize better because it has seen a lot of different training data.
The variability in the training data actually is a very important topic,
which has been shown. So we trained on much data, but the variability in
this data basically decides a lot about how good
the foundation model is.
And what was done in this study is they defined some measure of
foundation model robustness. So they define how robust is the foundation model.
And what they found was that, well, that's not surprising.
If you have more data that the model was trained on,
robustness goes up. So you can see that the models that were trained on many data
have also higher robustness.
What you can also very nicely see here is the blue ones are just
visual models. The orange ones are a combination of image and
text. And what you can see is that if you add text,
with less data, you can still go to a very robust model.
As I showed you before, if you combine text reports or captions with
the images, you get to a more robust model, to a better
performing model.
But what I also showed, and this is a bit of a complicated graph, but what I also
showed is that if you have these biases in your data, then a model that is
less robust also generalizes less.
So robustness of the model is very important because, as I showed you in the
beginning, if we have this, let's say, this training with breast cancer where we
have many
white patients and a minority of Asian patients,
we know that it will not function as well on these Asian patients.
And that is shown here very much. If you use a foundation model, you could do much
better. Generalizability could be much better, but only if your
model is robust enough. So it's very important that your model has a high quality
and is trained on very diverse data.
Now
I come to the end. So what can we do? And very brief,
let's say, overview of what could be done.
For instance, what you could do now, this is with ChatGPT, you could just have an
image and ChatGPT without training it specifically for pathology, you could ask it
segment tumor and tumor associated stroma.
And it can actually do quite a decent job.
Here, this is ChatGPT out of the box, and you can see it can distinguish
stroma and tumor.
If we then compare it to what a pathologist drew, you can see it's
okay-ish, but it's not great, right?
It does something meaningful, but it's
by far not good enough for any kind of practical
application.
Another nice one here, we gave it a lung biopsy, and we ask
the chatbot, this is a pathology chatbot,
"Can you say something about the chances that this patient is going to
respond to immune therapy?"
And what you can see then is that the chatbot analyzes
the image and actually comes up with very good
advice because it says, "Well, basically, no, I can't.
I need PD-L1 staining or maybe I need
tumor mutational burden analysis for this, because on the basis of this image, I
cannot do it." So it advises us to
take the next steps.
So this could be the future, a chatbot where you can talk to pathologists.
We will talk about this
later.One
of the things, if you're interested, is
one of the things I am involved in myself is BigPicture.
BigPicture is a very large European project where we try to collect lots of
data because, as I've showed you today, if you want to build foundation models, you
need many data, very diverse data, and BigPicture is one of the
projects where we try to collect as much data and as much variety data as
we can. So if you're interested in building AI and
moving forward with that, please have a look at our website.
BigPicture aims exactly to do this.
These are my sponsors, people that pay for our
research, and this is my research group.
We have a few minutes if there are any burning questions, and otherwise, at the end
of the session, we will still have a panel discussion where you can also put your
questions. But if there are any questions now, specifically about what
I just showed you, then please
let me know. You could use the QR code that I shared in the
beginning, or you could just stand up and use the microphones.
But what I can do is I can share the QR code once more for you,
I hope. Yeah.
Okay, thanks for the add-on.
Hi. Really cool talk.
I imagine if you were to put implicit biases in your algorithms,
for instance,
spherical equivariance with your tumor pathology images,
so the rotation doesn't matter,
that might help with training in making it more robust.
Or even if you were to inject noise
into the tumor pathology images, that might help robustness.
Are these things that you have explored at all?
Yeah, basically that's all of the standard techniques that we always use.
So we artificially change the images during training.
That helps definitely to generalize, but it's not enough to solve all of these
problems.
Got it. Thank you.
Hello, I'm Carlos from Tempos. I was wondering when you're using tile level
embeddings, what is the percentage of tiles that are important for prediction?
So when you look at the attention weights, if you're using some kind of
multiple instance learning, what do you see depending on the task?
Sorry, the sound is not really good for me. Can you repeat the question? Sorry.
Yeah, sure. So let's say you're doing multiple instance learning for a prediction
task using tile level data. So when you
look at the attention weights that you get there from this task, what is the
proportion of tiles that are actually important for the prediction task?
Ooh, that's a very tough question to answer in a very
general sense.
Okay.
I think we have very good techniques now to really figure
out which information is relevant, but of course, you will need some
decent amount of signal to be able to pick that up.
Mm-hmm.
But I think actually that,
yeah, probably you could get quite far, but it's a very hard
question to answer in a very general sense.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay, thanks. We don't have any questions online, I guess.
Okay. Then I--
Jana?
Hey,
everyone. Thank you for the opportunity to present.
So there are some disclosures. And
so I divided talk in three parts. First is a very short introduction to the
foundational models. There are going to be a little bit of overlap, but just to
make sure we are all on the same page.
And then we're going to look a lot on the benchmarking of foundational models with
special focus on prognostic predictions.
And then I show you some of our recent work, how we are trying to improve the
foundational models for prognosis.
So this is how typical deep learning pipeline look like before foundational
models in the natural images. So you have your image as a first step.
You're going to extract features from the images.
You end up with the feature vector, as we just saw.
And on the top of the feature vector, you're going to train your prediction model.
And in the natural images, what we did before foundational model, it's so-called
end-to-end learning. It means the model has to learn how to extract the features,
how to make the predictions. It has to learn all these components together.
And you saw that
AI is very good with image analysis, and this model get fantastic
performance, but they were trained on set of millions of images, so it's really
large scale data. When we move to pathology,
someone mentioned the multiple instance learning. This is how we handle the images.
The images are huge. So we segment the tissue in the image.
We divide the image into patches. Then we're going to extract features from the
patches, and then we do some other operation, how to integrate information from the
patches to build slide level representation, and we're going to do the predictions.
Now, because we don't have millions of pathology images, we cannot really train
this model end to end, and usually we don't do that.
So the idea was to use transfer learning, and
the observation is if you train your model on natural images, the early layers of
this network's going to learn specific general image features like
the color, shapes, intensities, and the later layer learn features that are
relevant for the prediction of cats and dogs and other
task. So what we do, we cut off the later layers,
and we use the earlier layers to extract features, and we use it as a
feature encoder for the histology images.
So we leverage the information from the natural images to learn image features, and
then we can extract features from the histopathology images, and we just
modify. So this is how we were able to train the models on
histology images that reach human level performance for a lot of task.
But these models were trained on something of order of ten thousands of images.
So for instance, Paige AI Prostate was trained on 60,000 images.
It's the model that reached the first FDA approval.
But we didn't need millions of images, but just ten thousands of
images.One observation is this
transfer learning is great, but there is still a big difference between
pictures of cats and dogs and cancer.
So the models still need a relatively large amount of data to learn tissue-specific
features. So if we can pre-train the models on histology-specific data,
maybe we have better features, and we can do better transfer learning.
Of course, we don't have millions of labeled histology images, but we have a large
amount of unlabeled images, and this is where the self-supervised learning is
coming to game.
So the objective of self-supervised learning is to learn specific tissue
representations that can be used for many different tasks.
And we saw it from York. This is like a simplified version.
You train this model doing different prediction tasks.
For instance, this is a very simplified cartoon.
You can take the image, you remove part of the image, and you train the model to
predict the missing part of the image.
This doesn't have any clinical meaning, but it forces the model to learn features
that are specific
for histology data. It helps the model to understand what does it mean to be
histology tissue.
And then we can use this pre-trained encoder to extract features from the images.
And encoders trained in this way, this
is what we call the foundation model.
And depending on the type of encoders we have, we're going to have different types
of foundational models. So we have patch level foundational models, which give you
features for individual patches in the image, or we can also have a slide-level
foundational models that give you a single feature vector for the whole slide
image. So they already agglomerate information from individual patches and give you
a single vector for a whole slide image.
And these
foundational model works only with the images.
So they're like unimodal foundational models.
But then we also have multimodal foundational models. We already saw the figure.
Here, the idea is we want to combine images and additional modality,
usually text, and we use it to learn better feature
representation. So I will spend a little bit more because I will get
back to this later. So usually, we use CLIP-style methods.
So there is this contrastive learning.
So the idea is the model have to learn text representation and image
representation jointly in a way that it's going to map them in a feature space.
So you want to find such a representation that a text and
an image are close to the feature space, or images with similar text
descriptions should be closer in a feature space.
So basically, use the text information to learn better feature representations, and
then again, you can use it as a feature encoder.
And in pathology, we have majority models going to be a combination of
images and text. So it's like visual language models, but we also have a
foundational model that were trained using images and transcriptomics data.
So there is, for instance, Tango model using the same approach.
So as we saw, foundational models help us to train more accurate models using less
training data and also more robust predictions.
So I will go very quickly because we already saw it.
This slide basically show in yellow is the ResNet, is the
baseline model, and all others are foundational models.
So you can see large improvement in the performance.
They are more data efficient, so you can see performance foundational models with
really small amount of data, like having 10 or 20 samples, it's already
sufficient to gain really high performance for certain tasks.
And this is another example that they can also reduce bias.
So here, different color correspond to different demographic subgroups.
And the last three are models using foundational models as a baseline.
So you can see there is less variability between the different demographic
subgroups.
This is a bit outdated landscape of foundational models in pathology.
At some point, I stopped updating it.
But you can see the first models came in 2021, and since then, many more models
have been added.
And just to appreciate the scale of the data they were trained.
So PyCon is our smallest model that was trained on something like 6,000 images,
which is as large as Giraffe, if you would stack the slides on the top of each
other. VirWho was trained on 1.5 million images, so it's going to be
as big as four Eiffel Towers. So it's a lot of data.
And different models use more data.
And basically, you can see every few months, new foundational model is being
published, each claim that it's superior to the previous one.
So you as a user may be asking, which one should you use?
And this is where the benchmarks in pathology came in.
The first benchmark was by Gabriel Campanella, where he compared a
few different foundational models on cancer detection and biomarker prediction
task. And here you can clearly see the blue is the ResNet performance
model. So you can see that the foundational model outperformed the ResNet 50
strongly.
They also showed that there was no clear winner.
So in different tasks, the different models performed better.
But what was interesting to see that larger models are not necessarily the best
one. Sometimes the PyCon, which was trained with 6,000 images, it's better than
VirWho with 3 millions images.
Then there was another benchmark from Jakob group, which was exhaustive,
like 20 models or something.
And this is just overview of the four best performing models, and they saw that
CONCH, which is the multimodal model combining images and text, was usually
better than the other models.
And this benchmark provided also more insights on the architecture.
So they showed that having more slides or more parameters does
at some point will reach a plateau, and adding more data doesn't necessarily help.
But they show that having more patients or different anatomical
sites
still improve the model. So
rather than having
larger models, we want to have better data.
So more patients, more anatomical sites is better than number of slides.
And these benchmarks, what is important, they were tested on private data, so it's
independent evaluation.
But we still have a few questions, like how we can move forward.
So all these benchmarks were doing mainly binary classification or classification
tasks. So one question was, how does it translate to other more complex tasks like
a survival prediction? What about generalization to external cohorts?
Differences between unimodal, multimodal slide versus patch level models.
And also now, because these are private cohorts,
if you develop new foundational models, we don't know anymore how to compare with
the previous one. So we were thinking it would be good to have some public
benchmark.And we develop our own benchmark, which we
then call PATOS, and it's focused on survival prediction in
oncology, because for survival prediction, it's difficult to build large cohorts.
So the question is: Can we benefit from foundational
models having better performance on smaller cohorts?
So this framework, we look at 13 different cancer types.
We have a mix of different models like unimodal, multimodal, patch level versus
slide level, and we also look at generalization to external cohorts.
And it's going to be public, so you can use the same split, same configuration.
So when you develop new foundational model, you just compare with the previous
ones.
And we're looking at a few different tasks.
One is cancer-specific models, like here you're going to train single model for
each disease. Like for the brain cancer, you're going to train model for brain
cancer survival, and then inference time, you use the same model to predict
survival for the brain cancer patients.
We also look at feasibility of having pan-cancer generalized models.
It's like, can we have one model for everything?
So we train one model across all the different cancer types, and then you can apply
the same model to all the different cancer types.
And here the idea is there may be some shared hallmarks of cancer that the model
can learn, and it can help you to generalize across different cancer types.
And we look at different performances.
This is average seen next across, I think, 50 different tasks
and generalization to external cohorts.
And one thing that you can see here, now you have to really read which one is the
ResNet as the baseline. So there is not that much improvement in survival
prediction over the ResNet 50. But still we see that, for instance, CONJ is
doing better than the other models, but there are no big differences between
foundational models. So one observation was
that larger foundation models were not necessarily better.
There is no clear winner,
although CONJ was the best performing, but we think it's maybe because of the data
diversity.
We also look what is the difference between slide-level versus patch-level
foundational models. And we saw that patch-level models actually are better than--
for survival prediction, they do better than slide-level models.
And we think it's because the models have more flexibility to look at the different
tissue regions rather than having single vector, which may be a bit
constraining. If you look at the difference between unimodal versus
multimodal model, there was no statistical difference for survival prediction
using these 10 models that we are looking at.
And we think this is a bit surprising because you would hope that maybe tangle with
the transcriptomics data going to help with the survival prediction.
The problem is that the way the foundational models are built, they don't
leverage the prognostic information.
Also, you have images and you have the text, but there is no additional prognostic
information. So even though these multimodal models perform better
for classification tasks, they don't provide that much benefit for prognostic
predictions. And we get back to that.
And we saw that in comparison between pan-cancer model and
cancer-specific model, the pan-cancer model perform a little bit better, so it was
feasible to have single model for all the applications.
One small thing you can do with this pan-cancer model, since you have one model
train on all the data, now you can apply it to any cancer type you
have. You can look how this model perform on out-of-distribution cancer.
So like we train the model on 10 most common cancer type, and we want to know how
they generalize to cancers that were not part of the model training.
You can think about rare diseases. How does the model generalize?
This is more like an interesting observation. So this is the ResNet 50.
It doesn't do very well on
out-of-distribution cases, and this is good. We will expect that.
There is little bit of mix of performance on the out-of-distribution cases for
some of the models have better than random performance.
And then for the slide-level foundational models, because we have single feature
vector, we can train them having more
larger patch size and better-- I'm sorry, larger batch size and more
better loss function. So this is going to be-- Oops.
This is performance having larger batch size and different loss function.
And you can start to see that even though the model never saw some of these
out-of-distribution cases, it was able to generalize it, like interesting
observation toward having generalized models.
Not something to be used in practice, but interesting that we can generalize across
diseases.
One way-- oh, this is kind of important.
So we were also looking at interpretability of the models having this
attention heat map. So here this colorful map tell us what are the
prognostic regions for each model prediction.
And one take home message here is you can see the heat maps are not the same across
the foundational models, even though we are doing the same task.
So this is maybe something to be cautious about because people consider to
use the high attention regions for biomarker
exploration, but it depend on the choice of foundational model.
So this is something we still maybe need to be careful about.
The observation was, this is example of this out-of-distribution
cases where the model was trained and some models like CONJ and Virchow, they were
still able to find a tumor region, even though the model never saw this type of
cancer. But it's interesting observation.
But we have to be careful with interpretability.
Another way to do interpretability is to look at the UMAPs.
So here we take features extracted from the data,
from the raw models, not trained for any specific task, and you can color it by the
different cancer types. And we see that foundational models, they're doing very
well separating different diseases in different subtypes.
But now if you color it with respect to survival, you see it's very random.
They are not better than ResNet. So this is what we saw the
improvements on survival prediction wasn't so great with
foundational model as we saw for the classification task, and it's because these
feature don't carry additional prognostic information.
So we decide to address it.
We propose our own model. It's called Surfer because it's from California.
Surfer is foundational model that is optimized for prognostic predictions,
and it's a clip-and-sell model that's going to combine, again, images and text.
But in contrast to previous models like CONJ, which combine histology image
and text that describe the same image, so it's like pathology report,
Surfer is going to combine images with the text, but the text contain
patient outcomes. So we have information on survival treatment
response.Also the idea is we want to inject this
prognostic information in the text description so the model can use it to learn
different prognostic features in the images.
If you just use the CONV on its native way, it's a little bit tricky
because it tries to push images
with similar text together. But
CLIP on its own doesn't have a notion of the time.
It doesn't know that patient with survival of six months and eight months should be
close in a feature space versus someone who has survival six months versus 20
months should be more far in space.
So we introduced this version of SoftCLIP, which is like a weighted version of
CLIP, which introduces additional weightening based on the distance in the feature
space. And it is to help the model to account for
discontinuity of time. So patients who have similar survival now are going to be
pushed closer together in a feature space, and those that have dissimilar survival
will be pushed far away. And in this way, we can also now include patients with
censored information because we just know when the
patient was last observed, but we can still use it to push them apart from a
patient that had very short survival.
So this is the outline of the SURFER model.
As a proof of concept, we trained SURFER using Titan as a
backbone. So Titan is a vision language foundational model, which gives
slide-level representation. So the SURFER uses Titan as a backbone,
and it was trained on set of approximately 15,000 whole slide images from
TCGA and from NIH-PLCO trial.
And so if we look at the UMAPs between
Titan versus SURFER colored with respect to the different cancer type, they are all
similar. So SURFER is still able to separate different disease subtypes, so we
didn't mess up the features too much.
But now if we start looking at the features for a specific cancer, and we color
them with respect to the survival.
So on the top you can see we have bladder cancer and
colorectal cancer,
and at the top is performance with the SURFER.
And you see there is no notion of the different risk groups for the patient
with the same cancer type. But with the SURFER, because of this SoftCLIP
pre-training, you can see a nice gradient of the different risk groups with
respect to survival. So the model was able to find and stratify the patient with
the same disease given the different risk groups.
So it's like we are starting to learn some prognostic features.
And then having better features, of course, you can translate it, and once you
train the downstream models for survival prediction, it results in better
survival prediction. So here in purple is Titan and dark is
SURFER. So we could reach better survival performance.
I don't claim that SURFER is the best solution.
This is just the idea. Maybe we can benefit and improve the self-supervised
learning and look at it slightly different to learn better prognostic features or
features relevant for different outcomes.
So this would be just to summarize.
So what we saw, foundational models allow us to train more accurate and
robust models while using less training data.
We saw for developing foundational models, having more data doesn't
necessarily mean
better performance, but having better quality of the data, more patients, more
diseases led to better representation.
And we also saw that existing foundational models, they didn't perform so well for
prognostic predictions. They are very good at separating patients with different
disease type, but they don't stratify a patient with the same disease type with
respect to the risk because there was no prognostic information included.
And also one of these motivations, maybe we can move beyond standard
self-supervised learning and try to inject additional information to learn
better features maybe relevant for the prognostic.
So again, I don't claim SURFER is the best direction, but it's suggestions maybe
we can start looking at different ways to better leverage the data.
Maybe it's not really self-supervised, but semi-self-supervised because we kind of
inject the survival there.
So maybe there is a space for other advances.
And to move forward, of course, there is need for transparency.
We have all these foundational models we don't know what they were trained on.
They may be sensitive to different scanner types, different disease types, so it's
like we would need more transparency.
Having benchmarks is super helpful.
It'll help us to understand what works for different data, what doesn't work,
how to improve this model to move forward.
Having private benchmark, like what Jacob and Gabriel did, is super helpful because
it's independent testing, but also having public benchmark as our partners can be
helpful because now if you develop own foundational models, you can just compare
with the other models and see how they are doing.
And the big question is how do we translate all of this to clinical practice?
How do we benefit from these foundational models?
What are the regulatory approvals?
And I don't know, but Jacob's going to tell us more about it, so I'm curious about
it. And with this, I want to thank you for your attention.
Thank you very much for this wonderful overview. And I have one question.
So one thing I'm curious is that in order to train a vision
language model, we typically need a pair of an image
and a corresponding text, right?
Yes.
But a whole slide image consists of hundreds of image patches
and possibly with a single caption.
So I was wondering how can we train vision language model with this
contrasted learning in case of a whole slide image?
Yeah, that is a very good question.
So especially for the survival prediction, you don't know which patches are
relevant. They may have different risk.
So we use Titan as a backbone. So we extract the features using the Titan
as a baseline information, so we end up with a slide level representation, and then
we use the SURFER, the SoftCLIP model, to refine the features to
make them prognostic relevant. But for instance,
Tangle model, which is using histology and transcriptomics data, they
introduced a way basically the multiple instance learning can be part of your
self-supervised pre-training, and then you end up with a slide level
representation. So this is like an out of step we were going to expand the SURFER,
but right now we just use slide level representation as a backbone.
Oh, thank you very much.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. Just out of curiosity, do you calculate the cosine similarity
between the embeddings across the different models?
We did not, but it's a good question.
Thank you.
Just to see how similar they are. But yeah, thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for suggestion.
Thank you for the great talk. So there are some recent work
showing foundation models can carry batch effect.
May not surprising because they often train using all
the imaging data from one institute or one hospital.
So you do see that foundation model can separate different cancer types
much cleaner in the TCGA data. Is that possible?
Those TCGA data, each cancer type came from different institute or
potential batch effect or-
Yes. Usually, the features you learn with foundation model
generalize the world. They also first pre-train a large amount of data,
not always from the single center, and it translate the world
and generalize also to data from other hospitals.
That's why we have such a good performance with foundation models.
So I don't think it's learning the specific of the cohort, but for instance,
people show that the foundation models are kind of sensitive to the
type of scanners that were used across different hospitals.
So if you scan the same slide with different scanners and you use four or five
different foundational models, and you look at them in the feature space, you can
see different blobs. So there is some impact on how the data were
pre-trained, and usually we don't know what the data were used for the training of
the scanner. So there are some hidden things that we still need to figure out.
But in terms of cancer prediction, I think they're generalizing pretty well.
But there are all these hidden other stuff that we may not be aware that they are
still there.
All right. Thank you.
Hey. Great talk, Jana.
Thank you.
Alex from University of Chicago.
I'm curious about your intuition on additional modes of data that
you'll add to the foundation model training. SURFER's fantastic. That's super cool.
But I wonder if you think that we're going to need to add molecular
subtypes, demographic information to get the maximum
impact, and if that's the case, are we going to run into this challenge where
there's combinations that aren't experienced
in the foundation model training? So I'd like to hear your thoughts.
Yeah, no, that's a very good question.
In the ideal world, if you have all the information, yes, that would be fantastic.
It's going to help.
In practice, it's hard to know. Also, like now with the SURFER, we are
thinking, should we include treatment response?
Should we resistance, all that information.
So I still don't know where is the line, but in general, more
information works better, and I think if you have enough data, it can help.
It can also be that your model is just ignoring some text information because it's
just not helping or it's not discriminative enough.
Yeah.
That was basically my question. But I guess, I was going to ask in the
context of precision medicine in clinical
trials, if you're trying to
identify patients, stratify a group for a
response to a particular type of new drug that you would be testing.
What factors and what advice would you have for either utilizing
and leveraging some of these models or even developing something in-house that was
kind of tied to that idea of which parts of that multimodal
data really are something to focus on and make sure is balanced
ahead of time?
I don't know if I really understand all your question in detail, but, yes.
So we're also expanding SURFER to see how it can be used to predict
treatment response, and of course, it's just so much you can predict from the
diagnostic images, right? There are a lot of other things happening.
But the fact that the model can already depict some different prognostic
information from the diagnostic images can be very helpful for stratifying patients
for clinical trial
or just for helping with selection of the treatment.
And I think the next step is build more advanced model that can be
adaptively adjusted.
Once new information came about a patient, maybe you can refine the risk prediction
because there is just so much you can predict from histology from the time of
diagnosis. The patient has a treatment, all the other things happening.
So I think this is like a first shot, and then we can build on the top of it.
But I'm not sure if I fully answered your question, but we can do it afterwards.
No, that helped. You basically answered my question when you answered his
question, so thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Let me try to pull up.
Or can you pull up my slides?
Thank you.
Next.
Can
you pull up the slide first?
Yeah.
Let's go.
There we are. Thank you very much.
Hello, everybody. Thank you very much for being here in our session.
Thank you to these excellent speakers.
My name is Jakob Kata. I was part of the organizing
committee of this year's ACR. I'm responsible for the
AI track, and I'm very, very happy that we managed to
get many high-profile AI sessions in this
year's conference program. I think ultimately, the whole conference should probably
be about AI, right? But maybe I'm biased.
So thanks for
your support and for being here. Tomorrow morning, we will have another AI
plenary session at 8:00 a.m., which I'm looking forward to.
But now let's speak about
pathology foundation models, and the title that
I gave my talk is not entirely correct because we've heard a lot
about the technical basics and how we train and how
we use foundation models in the two excellent previous
talks. So now I want toSpeak to another topic
which is: what can we use these models for?
And this is relevant for cancer research, but also for clinical
application. So let's get started. These are my disclosures.
And I want to take this opportunity to take a
step back to make very explicit the evolution
of artificial intelligence in cancer research that we have witnessed
over the last decades. It all started in the stone
ages, right, in the 2000s or even before,
with methods that we now call classical machine learning methods.
If you have tabular data or you have features derived
from image data or other more complex data, you can train
these methods
for classification, segmentation, prediction tasks.
They work pretty well. They still have their role to play today,
but they don't work for the real-world messy, complex
image data that we encounter in cancer research.
These are methods that you can basically use in Microsoft Excel or on your
calculator, and they're still very important, but we have to have
more complex methods to deal with more complex data.
And these methods came along in the form of deep
learning in the 2010s, specifically in 2012, when the first
convolutional neural networks had their success stories.
And this enabled us, for the first time, to analyze
pathology slides really robustly.
And
deep learning methods, of course, deep neural networks, you need a lot of data to
train them, and then you can solve any pathology image analysis problem that you're
interested in. But this data abundance was the main
practical limitation that held the field back.
And I think the technology of foundation models
fundamentally changed this because with the foundation model, as we have heard
beautifully articulated in the previous talks, you
train one big model
one time, and then you can use it many times for many downstream tasks.
Sure, you need a lot of images. Sure, you need a lot of
energy to train this model. But once you have it, it's frozen
forever. It's there. You can use it forever.
And you don't need so much downstream data every time you want to solve a
new task in a new cancer type. And that is the beauty of foundation models, and
that's why they have been so transformative in pathology
image analysis in cancer research.
Another type of foundation models is large language models,
right? Everybody knows them. Everybody uses ChatGPT, Claude, or
all these models. They're also foundation models that have been trained with
self-supervised learning on language.
And this happened more or less in parallel, right?
And now these models are also becoming very useful.
One reason why they're becoming useful in cancer research is because you can
build AI agents around them, and I will show you some examples for
that. But before we go into the future-looking things, let
me focus again on the foundation models, on the image analysis, and what we can do
with them.
In terms of applications, what do we want to use image
analysis in cancer research and oncology for?
Well, for many years, the answer was object detection,
cancer detection, right? In colonoscopy videos, we want to
detect polyps. In mammography
x-ray images, we want to detect breast cancer.
In pathology slides, we want to detect prostate cancer.
So we want to detect cancer, and this works so well that
basically in all these examples that I just gave you, these models have reached
human expert performance. You can train a model that's as good as any human
expert. It's consistent. It has been shown repeatedly in large prospective
randomized trials to hundreds of thousands of people.
This technology is robust. The problem is solved, right?
If you have enough data and one specific question for tumor detection
problem, problem solved. Of course, it does not solve all of our problems in the
real world because there's more than
just a small number of tumor types and
there's many challenges. I will speak to that later.
But from a technical perspective, these
things are now very well manageable.
That's why we can also look at more complicated tasks, and
that's what our research group did for many years now.
This is an ancient paper from our group where for the first time
we looked at different questions in pathology
image analysis. Can we predict molecular
alterations directly from pathology slides?
So this is a more challenging problem than making a diagnosis of
cancer because you cannot even be sure that the information
is represented in the image. But what we saw in this study
and in what others have shown in hundreds of other studies is
that many molecular alterations leave a
unique footprint in the tumor morphology, that you can
infer them just by looking at the morphology.
And this is not perfect, but it's good enough to be useful in many cases,
for example, for pre-screening.
Another example, a lot of work has been done with-- What I showed you here
was microsatellite instability.
Another example is homologous recombination deficiency.
These are gene signatures that basically mess
up with the tumor genome at many
levels and therefore also leave a footprint in the tumor morphology,
which you can infer with pathology image analysis.
This even goes for other more complex
genetic or molecular changes in the tumor.
For example,
transcriptomic signatures that are correlated to
patient outcomes. We know, for example, in breast cancer, there is
established risk scores such as Oncotype DX, MammaPrint,
that
are
related to clinical outcomes of these patients, but
you need to measure basically the tumor transcriptome.
Well, here in this work and in many other studies that came out
in this fieldAnd it was shown that
just the tumor morphology is enough to infer
these signatures from morphology.
Sure, it's not perfect, but it's good enough to be useful in many cases.
This is joint work by Kevin Boom and Omar Elnahas who are here in the audience.
So if you have any questions, you can approach them
directly.
What this also enables us to do is to
undertake explainability
analysis in these tumors and try to understand which cellular
patterns are related to these molecular changes.
And for example, here you can see we can even train generative models
to generate low-risk or high-risk
image areas. And you can see that we can then look at these images and
draw conclusions from it. For example, one
of these classes has maybe more stroma or less stroma, or more
vessels or more lymphocytes or more myeloid cells, et cetera.
So we can inform all of these biological hypothesis just
by training these models on pathology slides.
All of this has been enabled and facilitated
massively by foundation models. In the past, when in
2019 we did the first studies, we had to train each model from scratch
to predict these properties of tumors from images.
Now it's much easier. We can start at a much higher level.
We just start with a foundation model, right?
And then we
train another model on top of it. So you need much less data.
It's much better generalizable, it's much faster. You need much less compute.
It's just now becoming very easy to do this.
And this is a figure that I adapted from
Jana's paper without asking. Sorry, Jana.
I hope that's okay because I think it
visualizes the concepts again that I want to repeat here about foundation models.
Which concepts are relevant here? You have data.
You train a model to compress the data. What you get is an embedding.
It's just a list of numbers, and with this list of numbers, it's much easier to
work with this than with an original image, which has many millions
of pixels. These foundation models can be easily
generalized to
go from unimodal to multimodal foundation models.
That's another advantage, right?
And then if you have multimodal foundation models, you have one representation
for multiple data modalities, which can be very powerful.
Powerful for what? For many downstream tasks, and I put some of
these tasks here, and we've seen them in the previous talks.
What you can easily do with these foundation model embeddings is
solve the example applications that I've shown you before.
Prediction, prognostication, inference of molecular
alterations from morphology. But also you can retrieve
similar patients. All these patients live in a high-dimensional
space that's defined by your foundation model
feature space. And then you can retrieve the closest patients,
patients like me, right? You can also retrieve closest patients for
potential clinical trial matching.
You can retrieve patients or work in this embedding
space to generate virtual trial arms.
So there's a lot of downstream tasks that go beyond these predictive
tasks that I showed you. So foundation models are really cool
and everybody's using them, and there's no way to not use them when you're
working with pathology images
nowadays. We've benchmarked them in our team.
This study has been shown
much more elegantly by
the previous speakers. And I think benchmarking is something that's very
important, that's generally underappreciated.
As we have more and more models out there, benchmarking on
private data
with
reasonable use case, with relevant use cases becomes even
more
important.
Now, there is a paradox. This technology is extremely
powerful.
It's not so difficult to train it. We know that it can
solve many questions that are clinically interesting,
but at the same time, almost nobody's using it, right?
Let's be honest. We've heard less than 10% of pathology slides in the
US are read digitally. I think it's even less.
I think it's even less than 5% in Europe.
It's very good in some countries, but very bad in other countries.
Overall, of course, most pathology slides are not
digital, and therefore these methods cannot be used in
clinical routine. And I think it's these barriers here that's just from
an article that we wrote a while ago about barriers to implementation, which I
think is still valid.
Now we are not facing so much of a scientific problem anymore.
We're just facing an implementation problem.
And sometimes for scientists tackling these boring
implementation problems, it's not very appealing, but I think it's what we
have to do to really reap the benefits of this
technology in
patient care ultimately,
and in cancer research. And I hope we can have some
discussions about this
in the panel discussion. We are seeing some
encouraging signals, though. This is a study
led by Gabriele Campanella from New York, where
last year they published a beautiful study, and many
people who are here in the room were involved with this study, where they
ran an actual trial, a prospective evaluation,
to use this technology for screening of molecular
alterations from pathology slides.
In this case, predicting EGFR mutations in lung
cancer just based on the pathology slides.
And it worked pretty well even in this prospective study.
And
I recommend you to read this paper. I think it's very elegant.
The study design is very elegant, and they can make very
good statements, very strong statements here.
It reduced the number of rapid molecular tests by
43% while maintaining the current clinical performance.
So it's not a perfect test, but it can be useful,
especially in settings that are not as well-resourced as
here, Memorial Sloan,
where this study was conducted.Now,
why is this technology not being used widely?
Well, I spoke to the implementation hurdles, digitalization.
Another problem is that
even if all the infrastructure is there, the
clinicians have to use it and have to want it, right?
Otherwise, it's not going to be used.
So I'm very happy and proud to present
this work which we did last year in our
European professional society, ESMO, European Society of
Medical Oncology, where among oncologists and
pathologists and other experts, we
had an expert panel that formulated a
classification of these AI-based biomarkers, a
taxonomy, and then provided
recommendations for how biomarkers should be
validated. Looking at hundreds of
studies out there and dozens of products, basically this is what the
panel came up with.
Class A biomarkers, class B biomarkers, and Class C
biomarkers. Class A would be using AI methods for
quantification of known biomarkers, right?
Imagine a PD-L1-stained immunohistochemistry slide.
Usually, a human would read it, which is obviously
faulty in many situations, right?
So you can train an AI model to do this, which can be very consistent,
et cetera. So here you're just replacing the
readout, which is very simple and it
only needs analytical validation.
Class B is AI for indirect measure of
existing biomarkers. Imagine this trial that I showed you
where EGFR mutations were predicted from pathology
slides. Well, here you're measuring a known biomarker with a
different method, with a different data type than you would usually do, and this
needs a little bit more validation.
Class C is novel biomarkers, where imagine you
have clinical trial data where you have response of patients to
a certain treatment, and you take the pathology slides, you use a foundation model
to extract the features. You train a model on these features to predict the
response, to predict, for example, PCR, to predict
resist at first staging, right? Here you have a new
biomarker, and this is the situation where you
need most evidence, probably prospective evidence.
So we are hoping that this guidance will help
us
take up these methods in clinical
applications. What is next? I want to spend
just the last two, three minutes on an outlook to conclude
this session, and I'm showing again a timeline which is organized in a slightly
different way.
And just on the left-hand side is what I mentioned in the
presentation so far.
Applications of AI in oncology and in cancer
research is in the easiest case, it's diagnostic
AI systems, right? In the
slightly more difficult case is predicting biomarkers
from digital data. But what
these two applications have in common is that you train one
AI model for one task, right? You train one model on
lung cancer slides to predict EGFR mutations, and the model can only
do this. This is not a model that you can talk to and ask
for
tourism advice for San Diego, right?
But on the right-hand side, you're seeing completely
different applications, generalist AI models, and this is of course where the field
is moving towards, because large language models have the
incredible emerging properties
that they have understood language, but also
semantics and world knowledge, and you can basically ask
them many things if you employ them in a
chatbot. And if you go even beyond that, you can connect large
language models to any tool, to any other software, for example, a
browser, web browser or your computer or the command line
interface. So large language models can conduct multi-step
procedures. This is very
powerful, and you can use it for many applications.
One application that we use it for in my lab is
for tumor board agents. In
a tumor board for a patient, you have pathology slides,
but you also have radiology images at multiple time points.
You have the patient history, you have laboratory values, you have genomic data.
So you could be tempted to train one giant
multimodal model on all of these data to predict which treatment is the
best. Don't do this, right? It's not feasible,
because the problem is very complicated and very high
dimensional. But you can solve this through an agent.
If you use a large language model that understands the problem and has access
to pathology image analysis tools, radiology image analysis tools,
and these tools probably include foundation models, right?
To literature databases, to PubMed, to the internet, whatever,
to a calculator, then you can use
this setup to solve complex oncology cases just
like we do in a tumor board. And in fact, this is what we showed here for a
set of cancer cases,
benchmarking this against human oncologists.
Nowadays, we even have to say human oncologists, right?
So against oncologists, and it performed
pretty well. And you can go one step further,
because it's not just a tumor board that can
be potentiallyAutomated by an agent
system, it's basically everything in a hospital that
happens
through a human that uses a computer. And that's a lot, right?
Actually, most of what we do in the hospital is a human using a computer,
ordering a lab test, looking at a lab result, ordering imaging.
So we built an electronic-- We basically took an electronic medical
record environment, and we built an agent that can
navigate this environment and can extract any information
that it needs and can order any test that it needs.
And then we can visualize the path that
an agent, the diagnostic and therapy path that an agent
takes when it's confronted with a certain patient and how it
solves problems. For example, here, a patient that ultimately has a
pulmonary embolism, and we again benchmarked that against
many human doctors, and it performed quite well.
And this is in press. So I think the
future is, of course, use foundation models whenever you have complex
data, but also use agents, and I think at next
year's ACR, we will hear much more about this
technology. With that, I want to end my talk.
Thank you very much for staying here up until the very end.
I want to say thank you to my research team, and now I think we have
some time for a discussion and questions. Thank you very much.
Maybe first, are there questions for Dr.
Katter about his presentation?
We share.
Thank you.
Dr. Kanter.
Please.
My name is Andre.
It's a pleasure to be a listener on
your conference room. Really interesting topic about
AI and
how they can
help us with
all of the stuff that's going on around with our health.
It's not really a question, actually.
It's a recommendation to have
a meeting with Andre Dobry.
D-O-B-R-Y.
His lab in California
making really good
AI robots. They
literally doing that by themself and-
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Sure.
Thank you.
Good.
Jacob, great talk. I was wondering in terms of
guardrails, so I think we face two main issues
when we develop those agentic AI systems.
One, we don't really know
in a quantitative manner the performance of humans.
Yeah.
So it's hard to know where to put the bar in terms of AI performance.
But also those agents, how do you put guardrails on
them to make sure that there is human oversight?
So given your experience, can you comment on that?
Thank you, Ben. And this is an unsolved problem.
This whole era of agents is just getting started, and we saw
that if you naively put an agent and give it complete control over
an electronic medical record, it does a good job.
But please don't do this. Right? So it could
go horribly wrong.
It's feasible, but we have to put guardrails.
When I
saw these data, basically, I thought which guardrails actually exist
for humans, right?
But there's a lot of guardrails in place for humans, and
we have to build a whole system including social
control and including a lot of things,
medical professional ethics, and we have to rebuild all this
for agents. So until we figure this out, we cannot safely deploy this
technology. Yeah.
And are you going to benchmark humans the same way you benchmark the agents?
Exactly. Right. So
when we do this, we find out that humans also hallucinate
quite a bit and do shortcut learning and all the things that
can go wrong in agents, well, some of them can also go wrong in humans.
So I think it's actually quite funny that having this
technology also allows us to reflect
again on what it means to be a human
doctor or a human.
Maybe before we go to the next question, Jacob, how does it work in
the sense of regulatory approval?
Because I know AI and regulatory approval is a tough one.
Yeah.
Especially in Europe, I think. But I can imagine for agents it's even more
difficult.
Yeah. So
it's very important for everybody who uses this technology to be aware of
some regulatory principles. But I think it's very easy.
If you have an AI model that is trained on one type of data to solve
one task,
that is a medical device in the European Union and in the
US, it probably requires FDA approval in the US.
It probably requires a CE mark of some sorts in the European
Union. But there's pathways for this, right?
And many of these products have come to the market and have obtained this
regulatory approval. So, this process is long and painful and
costly, but it can be done, and people have done it, so it can be figured out.
When it comes to chatbots, it's much more difficult, right?
There's tons of chatbots on the market, and all the vendors basically say,
I'm simplifying a bit here, right, but most of them say it's not a medical device
because it does not provide decision support.
It's just a literature research tool, so just use it at your own risk,
right? So,
there's a bit of a gray area.
When it comes to agents, it's-I believe completely
unsolved. An agent would
probably be a medical device, but how would you
obtain CE mark for an autonomous agent?
I don't know. And I'm not sure that even the current
regulatory frameworks
are sufficient
for this. So obviously, that's a conversation that we have to have
with regulators and society.
Yeah. Good point. Okay, next.
Sure. I love this session. Thank you for the enthusiasm, especially because it
was based on rigor as well, and not just the hype.
I want to channel your comment about infrastructure because I couldn't agree more,
and I face this kind of thing on a regular basis.
I work for a research foundation that put infrastructure at the
center of the portfolio of projects that it funds with this very
intention in mind.
I'd like to hear what your thoughts are on that and whether or not you're heartened
by other developments like seeing this organization
named Radial recently, which came out with a $500
million
campaign to actually do this unglamorous part of
infrastructure so that science and AI, in a sense, could be done
better.
Yes. I
would love to hear what Jeroen has to say about this.
When you say $500 million, our European minds
are exploding. So typically, we
operate on a much smaller
scale. But ultimately, I do believe, yes, we have
to renovate our whole infrastructure.
Huge investments are going to be needed for this.
We have to justify such investments towards society, like why are we spending
all this money for this infrastructure and not for other things?
I think the potential benefits of these AI technologies
justify this investment, but it's up to us to provide the
empirical evidence for this and to show that this technology is actually
useful. Therefore, we should make these investments because it provides,
ultimately, a benefit. Jeroen, what do you think?
Yeah. To me, it often feels like it's a catch-22 situation.
What we see a lot is in many hospitals that
people are interested in AI. They are not interested yet in
investing until they really see the added value.
You're only going to invest
if you see proof that it's going to help you.
The proof is not there because people are not really using it in daily practice.
So it's a catch-22 where we want to start doing studies.
And I think I fully agree, we need much more investments in
infrastructure, but it is very difficult.
Yeah.
I also have a somewhat infrastructure-related question.
I think the microphone is not working.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Is that better? Okay. Also kind of infrastructure related.
Dr. Lupka mentioned, not just needing more slides, but also
needing more patients and,
I guess, just more diverse training data.
If you guys could just comment on federated learning, especially with patient
data and medical data, and balancing
having more data to train on and having it be decentralized, but then
also having, I guess, higher risk in terms of data
security and privacy.
I'm not sure if I catch everything, but I heard federated learning.
No, definitely. So having more data would be very helpful, and we have to work
together if we want to have these general models apply to more patients, better
performance. And federated learning can be a really good way to overcome all these
barriers with the different data sharing.
So I'm not sure if I'm touching to everything what your queries, but...
In terms of data privacy and security, if you're dealing with medical data, if
there are just, on a practical level, more concerns with
federated learning over a more centralized approach.
Yeah. Data privacy, it's
very important, especially also with this model, sometimes you maybe can
predict patient ancestry from the histology images.
So we don't even know what the models are learning, and it can hurt the patient
privacy in some way. So I think we need to invest
better way for the privacy, for the federated learning.
We're just learning how to work with this large data, and we probably have
to rebuild everything, find the best way to handle it so it benefit people rather
than cause harm.
Maybe there is a question
from the audience
through the QR code. Maybe, Jana, you want to take that as well?
So the question is: What's the current major obstacle to train these pathology
foundation models? Are we short of data? What about data quality?
So what do you see as the biggest hurdle?
Yeah. So what we saw from the benchmarks, like what Jakob did and other groups,
we kind of already reach a plateau in terms of number data.
Like adding another million of data, it's probably not going to give us much more
benefit.
We saw that having better data in the sense more diverse diseases, more scanners,
different patients helps. And I think the next step is to
search for different ways to leverage the data.
I think it's just so much we can do with the uni-modal self-supervised learning,
where we try to play all this pretext task and maybe include additional
information in the text, like as we try with the server.
And there are probably better ways how we can leverage the data, and it's more on
model design advances that we need, rather than scanning
another million slides and so on.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. Next question. It's a bit hard to see.
All right.
Thank you. Good talk. Yi Shang Lee and postdoc from Dana-Farber.
I do genetically engineered mouse model.
I wonder if you could comment on the value or
limitations of mouse model, which is
autonomous
model tumors,
in training of the foundation models.
How can we help with
the training? Thank you.
You want this one?
Yeah. So the question is, I think, can we use data from mouse models as well for
foundation models, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's a good question.
I
don't think there's a lot of study, to be honest, in that.
But I could imagine that
organs from mice are to some extent, of course, they resemble
human organs as well. So I could imagine in your self-supervised learning,
your pre-training, actually, this data could come in very handy, but I have
no clue whether this was studied already.
But I could imagine that tissue structures to some extent are the same, so they
could actually add a lot of variability to that.
I'm sure if you have any-
I think an important point is that the magic of these
technologies comes with the scale, right?
These human pathology foundation models have been trained, as we saw in Jana's
talk, with hundreds of thousands, millions of slides.
And
we have actually in the lab done some attempts for
mouse-based studies of this sort,
and what we found is that it's much easier to get the
required patient numbers compared to the mouse numbers.
That's
just a very practical
thing. And then the other thing is that ultimately, of course, the justification
for all of this is to apply it for us as a clinical group,
the motivation is to apply it in the clinics where we have then,
of course, humans. But I think
it would be possible by collecting and aggregating
large data sets, even from pre-clinical models, to learn much more about
these data sets and learn much more about the diseases
that are represented there, and we should probably make
such efforts.
I like the questions a lot. Maybe one way to think about is we could
use the animal models maybe to enhance the maybe rare diseases in the pre-training
or use it to fine-tune the models for the rare diseases.
Or in the terms of toxicology, like treatment response or
for specific questions that you use in pharmacology, maybe for screening of the
drugs. These are data we don't do on the patients, right?
So this is where maybe animal models can enhance our cohorts and the models.
Yeah, very interesting. So I work in small cell lung cancer.
I saw you on your slides, small cell lung cancer is defined as rare, but
I view small cell lung cancer gems, which I always see.
So it will be very interesting to explore this.
We can talk afterwards.
Thank you.
Hi, Scott Anderson from Leica Biosystems. Really good discussion.
I was wondering how
you guys perceive these foundational models playing a role when it comes
to special IHC stains and computational pathology.
What,
please?
Sorry, I didn't get that.
Yeah, special stains, right?
Yes.
So the question is whether we can also include special stains
different from, I guess, H&E.
Yes, but also from a workflow perspective, would you see
in the future, these underlying models being
supplemented by special stains and computational analysis
of those special stains? We're thinking of a full digital
workflow.
Yeah, I think definitely. Of course, scoring of special stains is definitely
something that you could do with AI in general, I think.
And one of the use cases that we study a lot is also can we--
For instance, immunochemistry, we order only in specific cases, right?
We don't do it routinely for everything.
So what you can also do is you can optimize your workflows by, for instance, having
automated ordering of immunochemistry for specific
cases. And of course, also the scoring of immunochemistry or other
stainings can be done by AI in general, I think.
It's a very good point, yeah.
Yeah. So what we have-- Sorry. What we have seen is the
more diverse your training data is, the better these models get.
So if you can get your hands on very diverse special stains,
then put them in the mix for the training data, and it will improve the performance
as a rule of thumb, as we have seen. However, these foundation
models are even very powerful outside of the domain they were trained on.
So, for example, UNIPathology Foundation model from Faisal
Mahmood's lab, which was trained on human H&E
was also used for plant pathology studies, right?
And it works pretty well. So they encode very rich,
useful features even beyond the immediate training domain.
So if you have a bunch of plant pathology images
or any
special stains of human tissue, just try to use one of the foundation models,
and you might be pleasantly surprised.
So,
for the sake of time, I'm afraid that if you have any more questions, please
address us after the session, but we ran out of time, and I understand that we are
not allowed to go over time. So please come up and discuss
your questions if you're interested.
I would like to thank everyone here for your attendance.
It was a very informative session.
I would like to thank my co-speakers, co-panelists,
and well, enjoy the conference.